Oh radioactive iguana sounds like a
really bad band name standard Tabasco
the Saltine is good I'm more upset that
I ate the whole saltine ghost in the
darkness hot sauce oh god I'm so scared
of putting this in my mouth there's a
big tiger he does not look happy
it smells like salsa but it does kind of
like scratch a little bit more like it's
more painful than the other one but I
mean it's sweet it's good I like this
one yeah I think I like this one more
Belize and believe in that heat the
letters are hot literally on fire and it
has a heart well this doesn't look too
bad
cheers guys happen Mike throws the edge
I think my teeth are hurting here just
feel my sinuses clear a little bit Oh
scorpion from Trinidad I know people
return that and they do not and it had a
scorpion tail on it so it'll get you I
feel like this one isn't as bad yeah
oh you are you serious warning less than
one drop of this product is absolutely
an extremely it's seriously hot Oh
goddamn this is getting this is a spice
level that I've never felt before
rest in peace me and Moses I'm dying
like I want to imagine wait for the but
how much it's gonna burn